سبعه اشهر من القتال الدموي في ضخمه
الاوكرانيه تتجه نحو الحسم لصالح روسيا في
الايام الاخيره تعرض طريق الامداد الوحيد
لقصف روسي كثيف لتزيد صعوبه الحصار على
المدينه
قوات الروسيه التي تقاتل في المدينه منذ
اشهر اعلنت عن حصار المدينه تماما بعد
التقدم الذي احرزته في الاسابيع الاخيره
شمال وجنوبي المدينه طريق وحيد هو الذي
بقي منفذا باتجاه الغرب مؤديا الى مدينه
تشاسي فيار
رساله فاجنر جاءت على لسان مؤسسها الذي
خطب الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسي مطالبا
اياه باستغلال الوقت
اخراج من تبقى من المدينه
حاصله وحدات فاجنر عمليا مدينه باخموت ولم
يتبقى منها سوى طريق واحد اذا كنا نقاتل
في وقت سابق ضد الجيش المحترف فاننا نرى
الان بشكل متزايد كبار السن والاطفال انهم
يقاتلون لكن الوقت المتوقع في باخمت قصير
جدا لا يتجاوز يوما او يومين لمنحهم فرصه
لمغادره المدينه
كل من طرفي الصراع الدموي في ضخمه يدعيان
الحق خسائر فادحه بالطرف الاخر انهم لا
ياخذون في الحسبان خسائرهم في محاوله
الاستيلاء على المدينه بالهجوم تتمثل مهمه
قواتنا في بخمط في الحاق اكبر عدد ممكن من
الخسائر بالعدو
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه تصر على
الصمود في الدفاع معترفه بصعوبه الوضع في
الميدان بالتزامن مع سحب بعض الوحدات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه من مناطق سيطرتك
معركه باخموتيلا باتت تجسد الصمود
الاوكراني تتجه نحو الحسم الا ان القتال
المستميت وسقوطها في يد القوات الروسيه لن
يكون تقدما استراتيجيا حقيقيا لروسيا بحسب
المحللين اذا عمر العربيه